من يحتاج إلى تزيين الشجرة
برجال الثلج وسانتا في حين أنه من الممكن أن
تعلق الجان السيئة والمخللات الشريرة
[موسيقى]
الحلي المرتبطة بالرعب ، ومن هنا
جاء اسم القاتل ، إنه عمل لأب وابنته
خارج غراند رابيدز ميتشجان ،
لكن مبيعات هذا العام ماتت.
قادت ميكايلا بيرنز البالغة من العمر 24 عامًا إلى
نشر فيديو تيك لأبيها
وهو يسير في منتصف شهر ديسمبر ،
ويتجول والدي حاليًا في
مستودعاتنا متسائلاً عن سبب عدم انشغالنا
بالطلبات
بعد انتشار الفيديو على نطاق واسع.
بدعم من الناس
في غضون يومين ، حصلوا على العديد من الطلبات
التي حصلوا عليها طوال
العام 11 ونصف الشهر كانت ميكايلا
تسجل مقطع فيديو آخر عندما
اقترب والدها من السيارة التي كانت الدموع في
عينيه قد أنقذته  العمل ،
لقد أنقذت للتو هذا العمل
، ليس لديك أي فكرة عن مدى دغدغة أنا يا
إلهي علاقة دم مؤثرة بين الأب وابنته
نوعًا ما على عكس
نوع الدم القاتل المتسلسل الذي
استحضره بعض  إن معظم الحلي المشهورة على
ما يرام
، تمامًا مثل أحد مبيعات الزومبي
، عادت إلى الحياة
جينيموس CNN
لقد حفظت هذا النشاط التجاري في
نيويورك
[موسيقى]